- And that's the beautiful
thing with old school garage,
'cause old school garage, I
don't care what anyone says,
that's feel good music.
You'll be in a bad mood,
here's some old school garage,
put's you in a great mood man.
'Cause old school... We all
remember old school garage,
can I get a little melody
on the keys, please?
(garage piano music)
How nice is that?
Remember them? (laughing)
Actually can I get some drums please,
like a 135 bpm type a garage type ting?
(garage music)
(audience cheering)
You guys remember the garage singers?
They always had problems in relationships.
Every female garage singer,
they'd always be like,
they be like, they be like,
♪ Boy, you got me boy, got me um yeah ♪
♪ Boy yeah, you got
me, you don't love me ♪
♪ But you um boy, yeah ♪
♪ Boy, yeah you got me, but you know ♪
♪ Yeah, but boy ♪
Can I get some bass please,
can I get some bass?
(garage music)
- Yeah
Now my favorite MC was those
smooth geezer MCs, yeah.
'Cause they jump on
the mic smooth as well.
♪ It's the lyrical sound for the geezer ♪
♪ Geezer, geezer, geezer, geezer ♪
Then they come in with
some lyrics as well.
♪ It's the lyrical sound for the geezer ♪
♪ See this song love, it'll never chart ♪
♪ Leave it out and at the start ♪
♪ Julie, we love the bloodclaat ♪
♪ I said, Julie we love the bloodclaat ♪
♪ I said, see Julie, she won't desert me ♪
♪ She won't walk in my
life and then hurt me ♪
♪ She won't walk out of
my life like Van Persie ♪
♪ We like the bloodclaat tune
(foreign langauge) Mercy ♪
♪ I'll never do you
like Ghost done Tasha ♪
♪ Grime, cause I'm the pum-pum masher ♪
♪ The pum-pum masher, the pum-pum masher ♪
♪ Mash up the pum, I'm
the pum-pum masher ♪
♪ Pum-Pum masher, pum-pum masher ♪
♪ Mash up the pum, I'm
the pum-pim masher ♪
♪ See me mate, I'm the top geezer ♪
♪ Get two cans mate,
chuck 'em in the freezer ♪
♪ Get two cans for Sally and Lisa ♪
♪ 'Ucking hell, ah, ah, 'ucking hell ♪
♪ You slag, 'ucking hell,
ah, ah, 'ucking hell ♪
♪ Listen, when I say "Get
a couple", you say "Cans" ♪
♪ Get a couple, cans, get a couple, cans ♪
♪ When I say "Get a
couple", you say "Cans" ♪
♪ Get a couple, cans, get a couple, cans ♪
♪ I'm the guys says Get a couple cans ♪
♪ For the supporters, for the fans ♪
♪ For the guys in the Adidas Dames ♪
♪ For the guys who ain't got no plans ♪
♪ For the guys on the weekend
who go to their mom's ♪
♪ And then they go to their nan's ♪
♪ These geezers ain't got no friends ♪
♪ These geezers ain't got no fans, like ♪
♪ Get a couple, get a couple, yeah ♪
♪ Get a couple, get a couple, you slag ♪
♪ Get a couple, get a couple, you say ♪
♪ When I say "Get a", you say "Couple" ♪
♪ Get a, couple, get a, couple ♪
♪ Olly, Olly, Olly ♪
♪ Oi, Oi, Oi ♪
♪ We say, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
Thank you guys for coming!
Take care, goodnight.
(audience cheering)